in every industry there is some company
that really makes a difference and in
every one of those companies there's a
leader who really mattered our vision
and the Stanford executive program is to
help you become that leader our
curriculum will bring you to the cutting
edge in the latest thinking on business
excellence design thinking big data the
latest in financial engineering
strategic management methods for
innovation the faculty at the Stanford
Business School focus on why companies
win how public policy shapes the success
and failure of economies how people in
their careers change how negotiations
improve or hurt the chances of a
business how groups and teams operate
effectively to get the job done helping
you to understand what will make a
difference for you as a leader and for
your company as a competitor our
approach to learning and the Stanford
executive program relies on a great deal
of collaboration as you together with
the other executives in the program
share your experiences you'll carry with
you the network that you create when
you're here so that over your career
your relationships worldwide in a
business community will be enriched by
the six weeks that you had here
you will be changed by your experience
here in the short run you will have
specific plans and tools that you can
execute on Monday morning when you
return to work and in the long run your
career and your business will go on to a
different trajectory because of the
techniques and ideas that you learn
we're excited about the directions your
career will be taking we look forward to
seeing you here at Sam